Rhianna makes her steamy Bates Motel  debut as Celine Dion strips down on the  voice thank you very much  [Music]  Celine made her official debut as a  mentor for Team Gwen Stefani during  battle rounds on Monday night's episode  of The Voice contestants Jade chosen and  Kenny P went head to head and the 48  year old legendary singer made Jay so  nervous he could barely speak oh my god  Celine how were you let me show you a  pause for a second okay you okay Hoover  beavers eventually he found his groove  while performing with the band and  Celine was super into it pulling off the  air guitar and hilariously pretending to  strip down I tried so hard to get  undressed Selena got you yeah Kings also  got sexy over on Bates Motel  Rihanna made her debut as Marion crane  on the hit ane show Monday night and it  was hot  [Music]  I'm gonna be right we can't wait to see  what Norman aka Freddie Highmore has in  store for reread  you